. We've been speaking on the program about
the United States as a global laughing stock
under Donald Trump.
This is not just something I say.
It's the truth.
And we have new data.
Sometimes when I talk about the United States
as a laughing stock under Trump, people write
in and say, David, the world respects Trump.
The world knows Trump does what's best for
us.
And they don't like that because we win and
maybe they lose.
No, the reputation of the United States is
in the toilet.
There's a new Pew Research Center study since
Donald Trump took office as president.
The image of the United States has hugely
suffered in many countries.
The United States reputation is at a record
low.
Looking at the last 20 years, if you look
at the U.K., France, Germany, Japan, Canada,
Australia, in every single one of those countries,
favorability for the United States is the
lowest it has been in 20 years.
It is at the worst point now that it was throughout
the entire Bush presidency, Obama presidency
and Donald Trump presidency.
Right now, right now is the low point.
The numbers were already atrocious during
the first three years of Trump's presidency,
but it is corona virus and Donald Trump's
completely failed response that has really
hurt him in the last six months.
Only 15 percent of 13 major countries think
the United States has done a good job handling
coronavirus.
If you look at a chart of confidence in the
American president over time among Western
European countries, you see that it's sort
of trended down under Bush.
Trust in the American president was much higher
in Western Europe during Barack Obama, and
then it dropped even lower during Donald Trump
than it was during the George W. Bush administration.
And it makes a lot of sense if you pay attention
to what's going on now.
Very interesting.
If you look at trust in Trump versus trust
in other leaders across these 13 countries,
this is based on Australia, Belgium, Canada,
Denmark, France, Germany, Italy, Japan, Netherlands,
South Korea, Spain, Sweden and the U.K. across
those 13 countries.
You see that the least trusted leader is Donald
Trump.
83 percent across those 13 countries have
no confidence in Donald Trump, followed by
President Xi of China and Putin of Russia.
In other words, Putin and Xi are more trusted
than Donald Trump.
On the other end, Germany's Angela Merkel
is the most trusted at 76 percent, followed
by French President Emmanuel Macron.
And then Boris Johnson.
It is not about left or right.
Boris Johnson and Angela Merkel and even McCrone
are no extreme liberals.
It is not about that.
The world recognizes Trump is a buffoon who
cannot be trusted.
They think we're stupid for voting such a
clown into office.
Remember that Trump said on Twitter back in
2014.
We need a president who isn't a laughing stock
to the entire world.
We need a truly great leader, a genius at
strategy and winning respect.
That tweet has never been more relevant than
it is today.
Trump is less popular and less trusted than
Vladimir Putin and President Xi of China.
This is a pathetic joke, but it's a joke that
could last four more years.
The whole we should research taking bleach
internally.
That was quite a low point, even by applying
the most generous standards to Donald Trump.
And it has been downhill from there and things
are so bad.
I would actually ask conservatives, do you
really want to defend Trump four more years?
Or wouldn't you be better off just attacking
Biden for the next four years, like from the
standpoint of putting them in positions of
having to defend the indefensible?
It almost seems to me that it would be better
for them to spend the next four years just
criticizing Biden than continuing to defend
the absolute embarrassment that has been Donald
Trump's administration.
I don't know.
Let me know what
you think.